a quote that made me look at business in  a completely different way was the  following quote it said the harder you  are on yourself the easier life will be  on you let me say that one more time the  harder you are on yourself the easier  life will be on you now  some some youtube philosophers will tell  you the complete opposite be easy on  yourself life is tough  don't be so tough on yourself life is so  tough right yeah you're right i'm just a  little too tough on myself you choose  whichever philosophy you want to buy  into i can tell you 20 something years  ago which philosophy i bought into and i  know it's an annoying philosophy to say  the tougher you are on yourself life is  easier on you but it's just the truth